as if we didn't have already five or six
things happen this week that were
completely beyond parody
mike pillow you guys remember mike
lindell the ceo of mypillow we're doing
a class action lawsuit against all
machines yeah that guy
he has a new deadline
and
honestly at this point
is this just a joke because you can even
see steve bannon standing in the
background this was at cpac i'm pretty
confident over the weekend
again pillow says
the new deadline it's august 20 august
21 that's like ten nine eight nine ten
days from now
he says it's gonna happen we're gonna
see the biggest change the country has
ever seen and even though he's put
together what 15 20 different deadlines
so far none of which have gone anywhere
do people still believe this is it
possible someone is dumb enough to still
believe this i'm telling you after the
20th and the 21st of august the
aftermath of that you're gonna you're
gonna see the biggest change this
country has ever seen and you're gonna
also see judges i said this before
everyone says well mike what do you mean
the judges you go back a year and a half
not one judge looked at evidence except
for andrew county mission but he didn't
want to rule on it and those judges back
then they have families they have
neighbors they have grandchildren they
were afraid i'm telling you they were
afraid but in a year and a half later
after everyone's seen the destruction of
our country what's it what is so slow
that destruction have been the judges
how about those hundred if you have a
hundred people in your company you have
to take a shot become a junkie
question one is does steve bannon have
any idea what pillow's talking about
question two is does the crowd just stop
that okay how about the how about the
judge in florida that made the great
ruling about the mass mandates on
airplane chains our huge how about roe v
wade huh
so listen if you are still credulously
believing this guy after the
gigamillionth time that he has pulled
this act you just want to be taken for a
ride it's sort of like take my money
what can i donate to the audits to give
me something to donate to
this guy has been
first it was going to be by december of
2020 then january certainly by january
6. then by january 20th inauguration day
then it would be by march or april trump
was going to be back it was going to be
late spring it was going to be early
summer it was going to be august of 2021
then it was going to be thanksgiving
2021.
do you think that pillow even believes
this i have to tell you
from what people are telling me who know
this guy personally people in the media
and whatnot
he really seems to be off the off the
rails completely off the rails and he
may actually believe this stuff and it
doesn't seem to be untrue
that this entire thing flying around the
country with the machines we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines speaking at the rallies
everything it genuinely seems to have
have ruined his relationship with his
family
um so i'm increasingly of the mindset
that he does believe it let me know what
you think
we have a fantastic
membership program for the david pakman
show we do an extra show every day for
our members and all it takes to get
access is to sign up at joinpacman.com
that's it takes about a minute for
someone of average computer computer
with average computer proficiency
you can use the coupon code big voting
22 if you would like a discount and then
every single day
you'll get the bonus show
and you'll get the commercial free audio
and video feed of the show it's a
beautiful thing